okay and Dr coyote says that his
lecturer at Federal University of
Agriculture zuru kebi state Nigeria at
the department of animal science that's
pretty interesting
and we also have komal introducing
um her to us and she's pursuing MSC in
Biochemistry so we do have a couple of
MSE biochemistry students with us and a
lot of planned biotechnology enthusiasts
I'm also curious to know what uh what is
your current level of knowledge of class
economics is it beginner is it moderate
is it advanced
all right so with that let us begin uh
with today's webinar hello everyone a
very warm greeting to one and all my
name is
and I would like to welcome you all for
today's webinar on omex logic
transatronics data analysis for
biomedical data this is an online Mentor
guided program on Next Generation
sequencing data analysis in application
to Gene expression data with project
examples from infectious diseases cancer
and Neuroscience
and this program will introduce students
to real world applications of rnac data
analysis in biomedical research and
provide Hands-On skills and logical
background to extract insights from gene
expression data and in today's webinar
we will first learn to sign up on the
omixological and portal and learn how to
navigate various courses Associated
resources objectives and outcomes
finally the participants will be
introduced to the various subscription
options for the enrolling in the program
so before we begin with today's webinar
let me also take a brief moment to
introduce you to the team behind the
program
we are a us-based bioinformatics company
who is working with multiple academic
and Commercial collaborators to develop
easy to use analytical tools and our
mission is to make bioinformatics more
accessible
and as a part of the program students
will have access to the omics logic
training that has been completed by over
24 000 participants from 187 countries
in over 300 workshops and due to this
fast growth our team is working with
local and Regional coordinators that are
helping refine our local program
Logistics and adapting them to the needs
of students and researchers around the
world and this training has been
completed by participants in six
different specialization tracks that
includes oncology infectious diseases
Precision medicine Neuroscience data
science for biomedical data and
comprehensive training on omix data
analysis
some students will also have access to
the omaxe logic resources but how does
it help Advance bioinformatics teaching
omic's logic is a portal for practical
and theoretical learning of
bioinformatics it takes a combination of
training modules data analysis tools
curated project data sets and
interactive sessions with mentors to
give the student a clear path of the
Bloom's taxonomy pyramid and no matter
what the user's initial experience with
bioinformatics is or mixed logic is a
useful tool for gaining a baseline
knowledge of the theory behind
bioinformatics analysis of large data
sets and introduction to basic coding
languages like R and python or even
beginning a data analysis projects
this also comes with an access to the
omic strategy courses which includes
courses on bioinformatics Precision
medicine multi-omics that includes
genomics transatomics metagenomics
epigenomics data science that includes
using RN python as well as
cheminformatics
and example projects of different fields
which you could learn from and replicate
for your research work
the users will be given directions to
access BT by info platform for
bioinformatic processing and Analysis of
data the platform includes demo
pipelines as well as data management and
Analysis Cloud infrastructure to run the
bioinformatic pipelines and different
stages of analysis are performed in
different sections on this multinomics
platform
now to view the various courses example
projects and student projects you need
to first sign up on the omics logic
learn portal before that let me walk you
through a brief demo on what a completed
profile on the portal looks like
so once you sign up on the portal these
are the features that you need to update
on your account that is a completed
profile will have a profile image full
name with appropriate capitalization
link to your social media handles this
could be your Facebook LinkedIn
Instagram or kaidi or even Twitter and a
brief bio about yourself that will
consist of your educational background
and research interest
the mentors can view your progress under
the activity tab the courses you are
currently completing will appear under
the course tab finally after the
completion of your course the
certificates will appear under the
certificates tab so with that let us
Begin by signing up on the omics logic
law and portal before proceeding with
further details about the program
so for that let me share the link in the
chat box for signing up
all right
so here's the link for signing up on the
post
so for those participants who are new to
The omics Logical and portal and do not
have a previous account you can create
an account on the portal by simply
entering your email ID your password
and simply click on sorry first you need
to click on create an account option
that you see here and then here you will
be asked to enter your name email ID and
password and you can also have the
option to sign up using any of your
social media handles this could be
Google Facebook
Apple account GitHub account or even
Twitter and with that I'll pause for a
couple of seconds so that
um the participants can sign up on the
portal if you have when you sign up on
the portal please put a yes in the chat
box and for those participants who
already have an account on the portal
you can simply click on login now option
and simply click on sign in so those
participants can put a yes in the chat
box so that I know they already have
created an account on the the portal and
I'll help you navigate through the
various courses
and the program details that are there
so I'll pause for a couple of seconds
okay our car says done Sarah says yes
I'm waiting for other participants
yeah Tommy yes
done
if you're facing any technical issues
while signing up you can mention that as
well and I'll be happy to guide you
says yes
Andrea says done
I'm expecting more yeses and dance from
the participants and I'll show you the
various courses and example projects
that are there
all right so meanwhile the rest of the
participants are signing up I am going
to um sign in since I already have an
account on the portal
all right so once you sign in
um you will be able to see the various
courses and example projects that are
there on the portal so if you're looking
for a specific course you can simply
enter the topic that you're interested
in so for example if you are interested
in transatomic simply enter the keyword
drops atomic and that will show you the
various courses and example projects
that makes use of the concept
Transformers and let's say you're
interested in machine learning for that
you can simply enter keyword machine
learning and that will show you the
various courses and example projects as
well so now coming to the part where I
was showing you how to update your
profile on the portal for that click on
the tab that says welcome back with your
email ID
so once you click on this you will see
an option that says profile so when you
click on this icon it will show you how
you can edit the various details on the
portal so for instance you should have a
profile image your name should be in
proper capitalization you should link
your uh you should link your social
media handles for instance I've linked
my LinkedIn account and my work ID and a
brief buy about yourself so in my case I
have mentioned my educational background
and my research interest
and under the activity tab as I
previously mentioned the community
manager and the program Mentor will be
taking a look at your activity
coursework activity and various courses
that you start picking up will be
displayed under the courses Tab and once
you upload a research project on the
portal that will be displayed under the
projects Tab and once you enroll in any
of the program for example the
transatronics program that will be
displayed under the program stack so
I'll pause for a couple of seconds does
the participants have any queries
otherwise I'll proceed next
all right so uh now I want you all to
click on the programs tab that you see
here
and once you click on the programs tab
that will take you to the various uh
program uh lists that are there so here
uh when you enter transfer comics
you'll be able to see the main
transforming data analysis program page
when you click on that you will be
provided with various details for the
program so I'll share the link in the
chat box so that the participants can
view it as well
foreign
details that are listed on the program
page so first of all you can see that
the program commences on 20th December
and ends on 30th April 2023 and as you
scroll below you'll be given a program
overview of the transatronic data
analysis program so you can briefly go
through and understand what are the
various topics covered in a summary
twice
and when you scroll down below you will
be mainly seeing four key highlights
that is one is that you will see the
session dates for the program and the
calendar that is displayed here you will
also see the various session titles so
here if you scroll down you'll see all
the various sessions that are going to
be conducted as a part of the program
in addition to this you will also see
the various topics that will be covered
in each of these sessions as well and
apart from that you'll also see the
associated online resources that the
program Mentor will be making use of as
a part of the program so all of these
are hyperlinked you can simply visit the
link and that will take you to the
lesson or the coursework that will be
covered during the session
so you can browse through and go through
the program page at your own pace
so with that let me go back to my
presentation and let me walk you through
the various uh uh Associated resources
that you will be getting as a part of
the program
whereas the participants have any
queries so far
so you can let me know and I'll be happy
to guide you
has everyone visited the link has
everyone created an account on the
portal
okay all good
all right then so as mentioned uh
earlier one of the associated resources
that you get as a part of the program is
access to the omics logic loan Port
where you saw the various coursework and
the example projects as well as student
projects that you'll be getting a chance
to take a look at
and apart from that you will uh also get
access to the T bioinfo platform
so we know that high throughput
transatomic data analysis increasingly
rely on bioinformatic pipelines but
biologists often lack the required
technical expertise and often struggle
to work with transformix pipeline that
is why we offer easy to follow
transatronics pipelines that are color
coded as you as you can see in the
animation uh that that will help you
derive meaningful insights from complex
data sets so this is the interface of
the T by info platform I'd like to
request my colleague to share the link
in the chat box to the T by info
platform so you can take a look at the
interface and what are the various
sections that are covered as a part of
the T Bank platform
now let us take a look at what is uh
what else is there so again
data data visualization of options often
Empower biologists and researchers to
visually explore and analyze transatomic
data sets such as tables of gene
expression in a short and intuitive
manner that is why we have also
Incorporated interactive data
visualizations in our coursework such as
the multi-qc report bar plots volcano
plots and heat Maps so that it is easy
for visualization and another important
Associated resource that you get as far
part of the access to the TBI info
platform is the interactive dashboards
so to bring data and biology closer
together we have Incorporated
interactive dashboards for visual
exploration of complex data using the
open source plotly and most of these
dashboards are already available to use
by our researchers and are embedded on
the omics logic learn portal for the
students while completing their
coursework and another important access
that you get is the omics logic code
playground which will help you develop
coding skills while learning popular
packages in R and python to visualize
annotate and analyze complex patterns in
the gene expression data
and with so much data available on any
biological topic and question completing
a program seems like a great opportunity
but it can be challenging as well that
is why you also have the opportunity to
seek mental guidance throughout your
program to help you along your Learning
Journey
so now when you enter the keyword
transatomics there will be three major
courses that will pop up that will be
transatomics one which makes use of the
T by info platform and you also will see
the transatronics too which makes use of
the r programming language and you will
also see transform X3 that makes use of
python coding language so for so for
those participants who do not have a
prior background in coding and who's
completely new to the field of
transformix
then transformix one will be the best
course to start with so in this webinar
I'll be covering more about the
highlights of transatronics one so what
are the various objectives of this
course that is when you enroll for the
program and when you get access to the
term translates one course first of all
you will learn about the key
terminologies and basic concepts in fact
atomics and this will be taught through
lesson one biology of transcription and
lesson two RNA quantification
another important objective of this
course is to introduce the participants
to Next Generation sequencing with
specific focus on RNA sequencing and
that will be covered as a part of lesson
three RNA sequencing and Next Generation
sequencing
so so far we covered mostly the
theoretical Concepts now the course will
take you one step further and help you
understand the logical steps and learn
how to run bulk iron AC Pipeline and
this is where you will first of all
start using the T by info platform for
this you will be introduced to the
lessons for analysis of raw rna-seq data
that makes use of logical steps and
lesson five practical RNA sequencing
and then you will also learn how to
carry out the downstream analysis using
simple statistical comparison and you
hear you will also learn about PCA and
quantile normalization so here the
associated lessons that that you will be
covering will be data preparation for
Downstream analysis lesson seven
practical normalization and PCA of gene
expression data and finally lesson 8
statistical tests
and another important objective is to
introduce the participants to
differential gene expression analysis
and perform differential gene expression
using the D sec2 option and regression
analysis using the T by info platform so
for this you will be making use of
lesson 9 and lesson 10. lesson 9 will
introduce the participants to
differential gene expression and Gene
enrichment analysis and lesson 10 will
introduce participants to regression and
Factor regression analysis
and finally you will also have the
opportunity to conduct Advanced
statistical methods using unsupervised
and supervised machine learning
techniques and you learn to derive and
interpret important biological insights
after the analysis so for this you will
be talked through lesson 11 cell line
data and preparation Lesson 12
unsupervised machine learning and
clustering and lesson 13 supervised
machine Learning lesson 14 which we will
be covering in depth about the feature
selection and finally we have lesson 15.
which will teach you about how to how
you can go one step further to apply
your knowledge that you have gained so
far to example projects and even carry
out an independent research project on a
topic that you're interested to work on
so now you might be wondering after all
the coursework completion what comes
next so for all of that and more I'd
like to pass on the stage to Dr
raghavendra Lakshmi Narayan whose will
be your program Mentor as well so the
state is all yours
thank you very much recovery let me set
up uh my screen sharing and I take this
opportunity to welcome all of you to
this webinar and yeah
can you see my screen
Audible
yes
okay thank you very much so welcome to
today's webinar so as shrigori has
briefed you about the resources that
you're going to be going through
throughout the session so my part of the
my part of today's webinar is going to
focus on
um uh what are the data sets that we are
going to deal with and what are the
questions that we are going to ask with
the data sets and some information about
uh
sorry about that yeah some information
about uh what are we going to discuss
using example projects that we have
prepared for you to go through the
process of using a transcriptomics data
analysis to answer key questions related
to disease biology so that's the main
focus with this specific
um
section so let's without further Ado
let's move forward with my yeah right so
what have we learned so far so we know
that uh the development and the Advent
of modern genomics has provided
completely new ways to link targets to
diseases and to validate these targets
right and the result is for example a
potential for a new era of investigating
the trans this is progression through
regulation of gene expression and these
developments actually provides a mean to
mimic the mechanism by which our bodies
can accept regulatory control over a
range of normal functions and also
functions in disease or functions in
order state so in this program we will
discuss we will review and we will
demonstrate using data sets that are
associated with popular Publications and
public repositories to demonstrate you
different approaches that can be
employed for are using transcriptomics
data analysis to understand various
aspects of chronic disease biology so
how are we going to do that let's
proceed
during this journey we will also learn
about basic and translational research
in spit that is specific to oncology
right where the patient derives cell
lines which is a model system and the
patient derived xenograft models which
is a model system inside a mouse models
right
offer extremely good and Rich collection
of data to understand the treatment of
cancer in patients to understand
diagnosis of cancer generally and also
to specialize in Precision medicine or
personalized medicine so we will be
using data sets from patient derived
cell lines and we will be using data
sets from patient derived zero graph
models and we will be using datasets
from patients themselves so all these
three different data sets will give you
an overview of what are the methods that
you have to understand and that you have
to compile to analyze three the
transcriptomics data from three three
different sources to
um
all of them culminating into one single
aim to understand this is biology of
tumor cells right let's move forward and
in one of the examples we will take a
data set from publication modeling
Precision treatment
excuse me I think my yeah
yes so we will take a data set from a
well-known publication that is modeling
Precision treatment of breast cancer
right which was featured in genome
biology in 2013. this is a very
interesting publication because the
authors actually assembled 50 different
breast cancer cell lines and reported a
whole and represented whole spectrum of
breast cancer variations
um
including for example
results associated with treatment
responses results associated with
various um
molecular pathology and disease
progression
Etc so how did they do that they
integrated data assets from
transcriptomics data the integrated data
from genomics analysis genomic data and
also proteomics data along with
treatment response data to multitude of
different machine learning models to
understand generally the transcriptional
profile and to understand omics data
profile that is going to explain
commonly used explain responses of this
tumor two commonly used drugs so this
data set and this publication is very
very rich as I mentioned because it uses
90 different drug response signatures
and it uses for example seven different
molecular profilings and it also uses 84
lines of cell panels right so
in our analysis or during the course of
this program in the sessions we will be
using data from this study and address
some of the key questions you see
commonly used Advanced statistical
techniques like unsupervised and
supervised machine learning analysis so
in the unsupervised machine learning
analysis we will use a transcriptomics
data to understand
um categories of breast cancer that can
be
obtained or that can be identified using
normal clustering techniques like
hierarchical clustering like k-means
clustering and you will not stop there
you will further proceed into comparing
the results from different clustering
methods and how they interpret
transcriptomics data to give you an
overview of the categories that is
present for breast cancer and we don't
stop with that we also use uh
multi-ohomics integration like we
integrate transcriptomics data along
with the
treatment response data in the
supervised machine learning analysis to
predict treatment response and to
understand how transcriptomics data can
be used to
investigate uh tumor's response to some
treatments so
that we will do right and yeah overall
this project will actually help us
learn about how to analyze various omics
data types how to integrate them and how
to associate them with the phenotype
that is response to the treatment and
also different categories of breast
cancer right so this gives us
perspective on drug screening this gives
us perspective on Precision medicine two
um precisely diagnose the stages and
precisely diagnose the breast cancer
categories of the patients
so following which we will make use of
another uh publicly available resource
that everybody knows about the cancer
genome Atlas where we can actually uh we
will show you how to download and how to
access data from this uh public
repository and how to for example uh
compile the data so that we can perform
some transcriptomics data analysis that
is
generated or that is collected or
compiled from patients data right
we will show you we have a separate
session that focuses on our part of the
session that focuses on how to access
data from public repositories and how to
uh pre-process them and prepare them for
further analysis so once some of the
pre-processing is done basically what
are we trying to do is we will take
samples from let's say liver cancer like
liver hepatocellular carcinoma and then
um
using the tcga data from this cancer we
will try to link or we will try to
relate the patterns observed in the
transcriptomics data of the liver cancer
patients to various clinical data
available on those patients like
um like Hepatitis B uh infection
complication like the age at which the
initial pathological diagnosis was done
like BMI obesity or like geographical
locations based on based on the severity
or based on the complications of the
hepatitis B infection was actually found
so these these different uh clinical
data or different
um
risk factors can be evaluated using or
for example studying the patterns
observed in the transcriptomics data
themselves right so let's move on how
are we yeah how are we going to do this
so this is not
um
if you want a comprehensive uh
understanding of different clinical
characteristics that actually helps us
in uh
generating
categories and understanding overall
patterns of the hepatocellular carcinoma
then you have to definitely check out
the uh the cancer genome Atlas paper
that focuses on this liver cancer
so
in the end what will we get we have for
example scope for integrating several of
the mixed data analysis or omics data
and to use them to understand for
example let's say
um
um other the transcriptional or
transcriptomics landscape of the disease
the transcriptomic signature of the risk
factors associated in ETC so to give you
a a short demo of uh of um what are we
going to do and how are we going to
focus on what are we going to do with
the
um how to process or
um what are some of the important
findings from these results
um
we will take a subset of this data focus
on only 20 of the samples and when we
try to understand the patterns available
Within These 20 samples we readily see
that there is no pattern uh that one can
identify
um
from the principal component analysis as
an exploratory data analysis this is due
to a lot of noise that is present due to
this data being from the patient
resource of patient source and and this
patient data is being collected from
various different resources and then we
see that generally patient data is
associated with increased amount of
noise compared to the model system where
many of the different controllables can
be controlled but once we use Advanced
statistical methods like machine
learning analysis and supervised machine
learning and from for example
applying random Forest algorithm to this
data can actually enable us to use a
subset of
genes to understand the pattern
generally so instead of using all the
genes which results in an icy analysis
or noisy principle component analysis
output if we use a subset of the genes
we see that uh the samples very well
separate themselves based on the risk
factor that one can associate with the
with the data or with the samples like
we can identify alcoholism and hepatitis
B complications and we can also
understand uh other uh
diseases associated with the patients so
we see or we have
resources and we have lessons on how to
perform this analysis how to set up this
analysis and furthermore so we will also
use as a continuation of this same
project how to integrate uh
uh
multi-ohmics data like uh like gene
expression data along with micro RNA
expression data to understand
a risk factor again or to understand uh
um alcoholic
um
prevalence in the liver cancer and also
so if you have already access to the T
by uh to the learn portal so you should
definitely check this out and we have we
will also during the course of this
program spend a lot of time on this
project and uh focus on how to set up
the analysis and how to interpret the
results so that you can
get an overview of how different
Advanced statistical methods can be
applied to transcriptomics data to
understand this is progression as we
already spoke about so transcriptomics
data is not all about using machine
learning and uh with with the different
algorithms
um uh in fact most of the
transcriptomics data analysis will
actually be employed to
um
understand or to
elicitate differentially expressed genes
in the disease State compared to the
healthy controls so in this project we
will actually explore the
transcriptomics data of advanced stage
Alzheimer's disease patients right then
where we can use the differentially
expressed genes or we can
identify the differential Express genes
and then use that to annotate or use it
associate with the different Pathways
that we will find that are significantly
enriched or significantly suppressed in
the Alzheimer's disease patients
compared to the healthy controls we will
first for example explore the
transcriptomics data using normal
exploratory data analysis like PCA box
product Etc so subsequently this will
help us in identifying outliers and also
setting up necessary contrasts to
perform differential gene expression
analysis from where we can actually
scrutinize what are the important
Pathways that are altered in the
advanced Alzheimer's disease patients in
comparison to the normal samples using
uh over representation analysis Gene
Gene enrichment analysis and Gene set
enrichment analysis can also be
performed
so some of the uh projects that we
actually discussed example projects that
we actually discussed are actually
available in the turbot bioinfo platform
as briefed by
um
you know SRI gauri already so in the
platform you can actually go to uh these
drop down box that is our drop down
option next to each of this analysis
option that is going to open you up to a
lot of demo pipelines and in these demo
pipelines we can actually focus on
yeah in this demo pipeline we can
actually uh
focus on uh how this analysis is set up
and then once you get a
practice of how to set up this analysis
this actually gives you thank you yeah
this actually gives you access to all
the output that you can download and
then go through the interpretation that
is shared or that is discussed along
with the
um
along with the courses Associated
resources let me stop and reshare and
show you where to access these demo
pipelines from so that it is easy for
you to gain an understanding of how to
access this let me stop share here and
then resume share when I set up this
analysis
okay can you see my screen
no sir not yet yeah
finding a screen
I think this time it should be
successful it actually found it
can you see my screen I have opened up
the server debio info server yes it's
visible yes thank you very much so uh
next to each of this analysis technique
and Analysis methods we have this drop
down option this option actually opens
you up to several of the demo pipelines
and some of the pipelines will actually
use the data assets that we discussed
just now so
um this will not only give you an
insight into how these data sets are
used to set up the analysis and it will
also give you access to the output files
which you can download and follow along
with the interpretation that is referred
in the associated resources so let's say
we have the demos challenge projects or
the PDX project let's let's take this
demo silent project if you click on this
it's going to open up the pipeline
options to set up transcriptomics data
analysis the only difference here is we
have in uploaded the necessary input
files and we have set up all the
necessary parameters that you will learn
how to set up and how to uh and what to
choose during the course of this program
so this is going to give you a practice
uh or a preview how to set up this
pipeline so we start with this
one second yes then
followed by pre-processing methods which
are which will also be discussed
very slow today for some reasons yeah
then
it gives you uh clues or it gives you
highlighted options which is going to be
uh the theme and you are going to set up
a pipeline for your analysis also so uh
it's going to give you multiple options
that you can choose from and the choice
of the option will depend upon the data
analysis that you are setting up and the
question that you are going to ask as
you can see after the pre-processing I
have straight away opted to map it onto
the transcript and why mapping onto the
transcript why not mapping onto the
genome and why not perform isoform
construction these are the options are
the one that we will discuss during the
course of this program and what are the
limitations or what are the advantages
of setting up one data analysis uh over
the other will also be discussed in
detail
so after setting up this we can end the
pipeline
this is a simple pipeline which is going
to give you a table that uh
that is going to uh quantify the
MRNA expression levels of the uh
of the samples that we have uh in the
cell line State asset so you see you can
see there are several outputs that you
can download and explore so to starters
you can explore the multi-qc report as
demonstrated by srigori and also the
mapping stat which will give you uh how
good or how well your reads are mapped
onto the reference genome and I'm not
going to go over everything which we
will cover in detail and you have
options of expression quantification
performed on Gene level at the isoform
level with different normalization all
of this will be
discussed during the course of this
yeah during the course of this program
so let me again reshare this uh if you
have any questions then be prepared with
the questions and we will
so with that I want to pass it on to uh
next uh state where for example uh what
is the necessary to go through uh
these example projects and and and
understand uh the steps of setting up a
hypothesis validating the hypothesis and
Etc right so those are extremely
important for you for example let's let
me reshare here this is not foreign
can you see my screen again now I think
it's gone on to
okay
it's again trying to
find out
yeah so as a result of this program and
also as a result of you going through
your Associated resources right any one
of you who wants to start or start your
understanding in uh in bioinformatics
data analysis for transcriptomics data
can actually
uh can actually start preparing your
independent project as we come near the
end of This research uh as we come near
the end of this program so uh for your
project you will be selecting the data
you will be selecting the methods and
then which will constitutes to
constitute towards your own research
projects which
um we have experience of already working
with many of the students who have
completed the training and have
developed interesting research projects
that also won award and Publications in
peer review journal so to elaborate on
this and also to focus on what is
possible and to give you a sample of uh
the research projects that our students
actually submitted in our portal and
also available as Publications and
posters in publicly available resources
I invite srigori to uh continue the
session
and if you have any questions I'll be
happy to take it
or we can cross the sound pass the stage
back to she goes
uh thank you so much we do have a query
in the chat from falimi that is I cannot
access the data in buyinfo platform
so it looks like you are on mute
recently
all right let me share my screen
meanwhile uh
felony if you have difficulty in
accessing the accessing the data in the
bioinfo platform what what do you mean
by that
if you cannot access the key bio info
platform I think you should get in touch
hello hello Dr raghav uh let me answer
this question
yeah thank you sir so uh follow me if
you're not if you're not able to access
the data in uh T by info server platform
I guess you are asking that you cannot
upload the data or you cannot run the
pipelines or login or registration part
to upload your own data and do the
analysis on T bioinfo platform we have
different licenses or different
subscription which you have to subscribe
for and then we can provide you with the
credentials for the T bioinfo platform
to access the platform and do the
analysis further and the interpretation
part
so I suppose I answered your question
uh thank you sugar you can continue
oh yes uh we have one more query from
Shruti as part of this course do we have
to use the pipeline on the T by info
platform or will we be learning to write
code to run locally as well
uh Dr ragus hello yes sir yeah so uh you
will be using both Shruti uh we will
first start with understanding the logic
behind for setting up a transcriptomics
data analysis using the pipeline option
from Key bioinfo platform and of course
uh analyzing or of course running a big
data analysis for fastq files or which
can easily span multiple GBS and GBS is
not possible for everybody so we have to
do the um
quantification pipeline in the by a big
data by info server T by info server
only the downstream analysis you can
either continue with the pipelines
option in the tbio info server or you
can use r or Python's uh coding options
where yeah based on your comfort level
and based on your expertise
thank you so much sir so let me proceed
with the presentation so as Dr Ruger
discussed uh we will once you learn the
basic concepts and figure out how to run
the pipelines you can apply your
knowledge so far on example projects
that are based on high impact research
Publications and apart from that you
also have the opportunity to carry out
independent research project so here is
a look into some of the research
projects that have been carried out by
students ranging from high school
background to even top rate students so
the topics range from oncology
infectious diseases virology and so on
so here's a look into some of them so
one of the research projects that was
carried out by a student was in in
autoimmune diseases where she learned to
assess the underlying reason for gray
matter lesions in multiple multiple
sclerosis patients and in the chat I'm
pasting the link to her project so that
the participants can take a look at it
you'll be coming back to this project in
the next slide so keep a note of that
and then another interesting research
project was uh done on oncology where
the participant uh aimed to analyze
mobile biochemical infractions before
and after administration of drug in
cancer patients and you can have a look
into that as well in the chat I'm
pasting the link
and there are another another
interesting research project was done in
Space omics by a PhD student where he
learned to correlate the effects of
space flight conditions on the transit
term of zebrafish embryos and human
astronauts and the participants can have
a look into that project as well here's
the link
and uh another
interesting project was carried out in
infectious diseases where the student
focused on TB treatment in human body
and how blood transcriptome analysis
reveals the evolution and resolution of
the immune responses in tuberculosis
here's the link in the chat
and then we also have student projects
in Neuroscience where the student
performed a transformic analysis of
Alzheimer's disease to understand the
difference in elderly population and the
younger generation
and here's the link
and finally we also have uh investment
research projects on machine learning
here the student was trying to examine
the transcriptional changes that Define
different subsets of opioid use disorder
patients using differential gene
expression analysis and unsupervised
clustering
I'm pasting the link in the chat box as
well
so as you can see all these research
projects are um are in a format that you
can share the link and uh shared with
your community or in your resume so that
your peers can take a look at it and
apart from carrying out the research
project the students have also gone on
to publish their work in uh interesting
uh in leading journals such as here is a
look into an research project that was
done in the autoimmune disease that I
was talking about earlier here the
student went on to publish a project on
in immunogenetics and Open Access a
research journal and I'm sharing the
link to her publication in the chat as
well
and then there is also another student
who carried out his research project in
uh malaria vaccine and that was also
published in the genomics and
informatics Journal so you can have a
look at that as well so now before we
wind up I want to show you where you can
find all of these resources such as the
example projects and the student
projects
so as mentioned before when you enter
the keyword transatronics that will show
you a very list of courses and example
projects another option is to just click
on the transcriptomics icon that you see
here and this will show uh this one will
show the various example projects that
are there this will this is uh this will
appear under the courses tab that
um that gets long that is that is shown
when you sign up on the portal so here
it makes use of different concepts apart
from transatronics such as machine
learning and here is another interesting
example project on the infectious
diseases and so on so now how can you uh
look take a look at the various student
projects for that you can simply click
on the tab that says projects here
and here you will care you can see the
various student projects that are there
here also you can simply enter the word
transcriptomics or click on the icon
transfer mix and that will show you the
various uh uh student projects that are
there so uh with that if the
participants have any queries please let
me know and we'll be happy to answer
all right there was one question from
Shruti but it looks like it has
pronounced it
all right so uh if the participants are
having any further queries please feel
free to share it in the chat uh but now
I'd like to pass on the stage to uh Miss
fresh there to share with the students
the details for the program registration
so overdue Express
thank you so much let me share my screen
so could you please confirm shree gaurav
if my screen is visible
uh not yet it is showing started screen
sharing yes
perfect
so uh hello everyone my name is and I'm
the marketing manager here at Pine
biotech and I'm responsible uh for this
session to explain you about the
resources which you'll have access to
once you'll be a part of this program
and then the sessions uh the session
topics which will be covering throughout
the program and then the pricing of the
program uh and the scholarships so
as you can see that the first session uh
like the program is commencing on
December 28th the first session of the
program uh will be conducted on
December 20th 2022 and uh as we scroll
down we can see that there is a program
overview okay so here's the program page
Link in the chat box you can go through
with this link uh after the session gets
over thoroughly and if you feel any
question or you have any further query
I'll be sharing my mail address and also
the official contact number here in the
chat itself and you can directly ping me
on the mail also or the or via call or
WhatsApp so here you can see that
there's this is the program overview of
transcriptomic data analysis for
biomedical data program and in this
online program we'll be introducing the
participants how uh they can use the
applications of RNs sequence rnac data
analysis in biomedical research and
provide the participants with both the
theoretical as well as the Hands-On
skills
so that they get some insights this
extract some insights related to the
gene expression data Etc now as you move
further you can see here there is a
there is this interactive session
calendar and there are some dates which
are highlighted on this calendar so
these are the dates when we'll be
conducting our particular session on
different topics related to this program
and on the right hand side of this uh
calendar you can see there are different
sessions uh so the first session that is
on 28 December it will include uh
introduction to NGS transcriptomic where
the topics we'll be covering uh are on
overview of the omics Next Generation
sequencing mRNA biology methods of RNA
quantification mRNA Library preparation
Next Generation sequencing Illumina
microarray Oxford nanopore and then the
biomedical projects using RNA Sleek data
here also you can see that there are
some Associated online resources which
will have access to once you'll be the
part of the program and then the second
session would be on processing
transcriptomics data where we'll be uh
guiding you and teaching you about the
read quality fast QC about how you can
uh prepare uh the expression table
recounts fpkm then TPM gene expression
examples would be there there then
exoner Exon and Junction detection Etc
then again there are some Associated
online resources
and then the third is on projects using
rnse data the fourth is on loading rnse
data in RN python data normalization and
preparation for analysis data
visualization in R and python
exploratory analysis differential gene
expression then Factor regression
analysis biological interpretation
single cell rna-seq methods Etc and in
the end we will be guiding so whatever
you have learned throughout the program
in your training period theoretical as
well as a practically we will be guiding
you how you can translate everything
into a real life application by
developing a independent research
project out of it or or not if not the
project you can develop a proper
research proposal also uh so this is
what we'll be covering in uh
covering in the program now when you
scroll down you can see there are three
different tenures one is 45 days another
is 60 days and then is 90 days tenure so
there are some common resources which
everyone would have access to if they'll
enroll in the program and those common
resources are first is the online
tutorials
second is the example research project
which Dr ago indran and SRI gauri has
already explained comprehensively then
third is the coding sessions
fourth is the session recordings
uh then fifth is online mental Support
Online technical support via uh the
Skype Group which will be specifically
created for the participants of this uh
program and obviously the certification
after the completion of the program and
then you will have the uh access to the
example Cloud pipelines on the T bio
infos server so these are the common
resources which one would have access to
Once they'll enroll in the program now
in the 45 days tenure we'll be like
we'll be focusing on getting you trained
uh
in this particular topic and the topics
which we'll be covering throughout the
program and uh through the live sessions
or through the online Mentor support or
live q a session Etc now the difference
between a 45 60 and 90s in 60 days you
have two different opportunities the
second opportunity uh in 60 days uh the
the two different opportunities are
first is one-on-one Mentor sessions and
the second is uh the research proposal
so one in one-on-one Mentor session for
example if you are going through a
particular module of this program and
you get stuck somewhere and you cannot
wait until the next live session will be
conducted you want to get clarified your
queries in question if the query is
small you can directly ping in the chat
also uh via the online Mentor assistance
if not we can fix a kind of a short
meeting of your with the mentor of 20-30
minutes and you can discuss and clarify
your questions in that particular meet
now the second is research proposal so
once your 45 days of tenure is over the
rest of the 15 days you can devote to
draft your experimental design what
would be the data set you need to work
on a research question a title a
reference paper you are following a
methodology Etc so you need to Define
you need to create and draft a research
proposal to present it to your program
mentor and he'll be evaluating your uh
a research proposal if there are any
amendments or changes that need to be
done so as the research proposal becomes
more validated so he will guide you
accordingly if not then you can proceed
further by developing and working on
your independent research project also
and uh then comes the last tenure that
is the 90 days tenure so in the 90 days
tenure again you have two different
opportunities one is obviously the
one-on-one Mentor session that I
explained just now and second is working
on the independent research project
so once your 45 days of training is over
the rest of the 45 days we will be
guiding you the mentor uh the uh project
manager they'll be guiding you how you
can develop your independent research
project out of whatever you have learned
whatever whatever you have get trained
for uh and into a proper full-fresh
research project and the outcome of this
tenure would be either a poster
presentation in a research Symposium or
an International Conference or to get it
published in a peer-reviewed journal so
if you complete this 90 days tenure with
a summation of the project on our portal
as well as get it on our portal you will
get a certificate of excellence as you
can see here on the resources
under the tab so this is how uh the
resources are and this is the difference
between the 10 years now talking about
the pricing part so right now you can
see that the pricing is a is in INR how
you can change the pricing according to
your location how so here you can see
there is a drop down arrow once you'll
click on this drop down arrow you can
see that there are different
yeah so there are different uh
currencies which have been uh like which
you can see on my screen right now in
USD in Euro in Brazilian uh then in INR
then in naira Etc so according to your
location you can change the pricing for
now I'll be showing uh the pricing in
three different currencies one is an INR
second is in USD and third is in naira
starting with the INR first
so the pricing for 45 days for INR is
rupees 7500 then for 60 days it's 10 000
and for 90 days it's fifteen thousand
and right now we are providing with a 50
scholarship offer and those who are
interested uh they can ping us on my
email address which I'll be just writing
down thank you srigori uh for the
details so she already has already
pasted the or pasted my details in the
chat box it's
marketing.com so whosoever is interested
for the 50 scholarship can either ping
me on this particular mail address or
can WhatsApp me on the number mentioned
or they can put their email IDs in the
chat box itself we will be texting and
mailing you regarding that and providing
you with the steps of registration
further now showing you the pricing in
USD so the price in USD for 45 days is
150 dollars and then for 60 days it's
dollar 300 and then for 90 days it's
dollar 450. again 50 scholarship is
applicable
and um then showing the pricing in naira
so
so the pricing for 45 days in naira it's
ngn uh 50 000 then for 60 it's naira uh
double nine triple nine and then for 90
it's a one lakh fifty thousand so these
are uh these are the pricing for three
different currencies right now those who
are located other than these three uh
regions or locations please change your
currency accordingly and you can see the
pricing and apply the 50 percent uh
thing and that will be the amount which
is for 45 60 and 90 days it's applicable
for everyone and this offer is limited
till 25th of the December
uh so please uh if you want to Avail
this uh offer or opportunity please feel
free to Ping us and we'll be there to
guide and assist you
and get started uh with learning uh
and getting yourself trained in the
transcriptomic data analysis both single
and bulk so this was all about the
research
the registration part the resources part
and the scholarship part so uh is if
anyone is having any kind of query or
doubt regarding the process please feel
free to Ping in the chat box and I'll be
there to assist and guide you thank you
so much
thank you so much Parish so we'll pause
for a couple of seconds uh so that the
participants if they're having any
questions you can share it in the chat
or please feel free to unmute yourself
and ask your queries as well
yes and those who are willing to join
the program with a 50 scholarship and
you are interested so please feel uh
please ping your email address in the
chat box uh one of our representative
will mail you and follow with you by
guiding you how you can register by
providing you with the coupon code for
50 scholarship Etc
thank you Alma I can see you are
interested we have noted down your email
address
anyone else thank you Ashley thank you
thank you prajesh okay I could see uh
one
so it's okay thank you we have noted uh
thank you Akash
so we'll be getting back to you by uh
tomorrow morning preferably depending
upon which location you are located I
will be mailing you according to the
time zone
thank you everyone I could see that you
have pasted and you have uh pasted your
thank you sir in the
anyone else
so I guess uh shubham or like any of my
team member is uh noting down all the
email address
[Music]
foreign
I guess yeah I guess the people who are
interested they have pasted their email
address already in the chat box trigori
so you can continue
thank you everyone
thank you so much so if you're still
left to share your email address with us
you can also share it to marketing
atomixlogic.com and we'll get back to
you with a coupon code as well and if no
one has any queries left we are good to
end today's meeting and with that
um okay we have one query from shooting
I joined a bit late so this question
might be answered but as a part of this
program transcriptomics 2 and 3 also to
explore with python and R or is it a
separate sign up
so it's included in the associated
online resources Shruti transcriptomic
2n3 uh you'll be exploring both
it's not you have to uh register for a
separate program to explore Python and R
together with transcriptom and it's
there in the curriculum
yeah
you're welcome
all right then so the participants have
no queries you can leave the meeting
we'll just take a note of all the email
ID that has been shared and we'll get
back to you so thank you everyone have a
great day